look before you ask why are you
reviewing garbage Jeremy could review
anything well I was kind of on a doom
kick doom eternal was amazing I was like
going one more doom worst case scenario
the movies terrible but I hear that
experiencing the bad helps you
appreciate the good to be pretty
appreciative fun at it anyhow here we go
[Music]
doom annihilation so doom annihilation
in the vein of Mortal Kombat
annihilation is a very bad attempt at
adapting a video game to the big screen
or small screen and this didn't come out
in theaters I mean we got a do movie
before they didn't really feel like doom
and now we have a doom movie again it
doesn't really feel like doom what's so
hard about doom it's weird does like why
is this unmei Keable part of it probably
has to do with the budget all right I'm
gonna get I'm jumping around too much in
doom annihilation a group of Marines go
to Phobos one of the moons of Mars cuz
there's their experiments going on there
and and you know it all goes bad and a
gate opens up and now we have zombies I
really would have preferred that this
was called that you know space zombies
in space we've been more accurate and
probably accurately cheesy to what the
movie is or I mean it's on Mars so
instead of what Day of the Dead will
call it Sol of the Dead but ever you
want to call it it's it's space zombies
you have a whole crew of people you
don't really care about you waste a lot
of set-up time with this crew of people
you don't care about which I kind of get
because you want to shoot out with a lot
of guns and you want to see some carnage
and people die okay but I just quite
simply feel like you could have had that
without wasting my time instead of
wasting an hour and 15 minutes or an
hour and 30 minutes however long it took
to be like oh I think doom might start
to happen now there's an intro you could
have had for this movie you could have
had it happen before the titles even
came up yeah this movie start out how it
actually initially does start out guy
goes through a portal then always like a
zombie and then just have a bunch of
things start flooding through the portal
and infecting people people tearing each
other up and there is a group of Space
Marines and then they get into a crazy
super zombie firefight and they get
wiped out in glory bloody fashion then
an imp pops up and then just shoots a
fireball at the last one hits him he
falls down a chasm boom he's dead cut
the title doom only he's not dead he's
the last one standing I was gonna cut
down all these demons making his way you
know to get home or burn them down or
both or you could do what this movie
doesn't waste an hour and 20 minutes
with a crew we don't really care about
because I don't know attempt at doom
because when video game adaptations
happen annihilation and the subtitle
it's just not a good thing to have and
most of it is probably budge I mean you
look at the array of demons that doom
has whether it be the imps which granted
imps are actually in it they shoot
fireballs I'll give credit conceptually
conceptually because the fireballs look
like Adobe
to effects it doesn't look good but at
least the Imps did throw fire false
whether it be the remanence the manka by
arch-vile which yeah they've been in
doom before doom eternal they iced my
bad after I got corrected on that in the
comments section I was like did they and
I look it up on YouTube it was like oh
that [ __ ] totally yeah I blocked that
out pain in the ass in any case
cyberdemons point is is a great array of
doom demons but they probably just
didn't have the budget to make them in
this movie which is right there
therein lies the lesson don't take on a
doom movie unless you have the budget to
make a dumb movie cuz what we actually
end up getting in this movie is a bunch
of zombies and a couple of hips that's
it and there was actually the biggest
monster probably scariest monster in the
entire thing - the script which is funny
because in other movies you see the
finger prints of doom and they're more
doom than the doom movies we've actually
gotten it's like if you take the set
design creature design an isolated
feeling of Pandorum not necessarily the
group of Marines but the onslaught of
enemies from aliens the concept and some
of the tone from event horizon and that
one man army action film feeling of any
number of babies action movies you might
just combine them all to make an
effective doom movie or we can just keep
making garbage there's that too I mean
credit where credit's due for the last
doom movie like the other doom movie
with the rock and Karl Urban I think
Karl Urban would be an awesome doom
Slayer as seen from Dredd at least the
other doom movie had that first-person
segment which I thought was gonna be the
stupidest part of the movie when I saw
it in one of the ads but it actually
turned out to be the coolest part of the
movie and it actually had one of the
pinky's which gives it one more demon
than this movie has it's like the
callbacks in Doom annihilation are just
cheesy callbacks I mean exploding barrel
I like that chainsaw cool this what dude
in the fire fight goes I'm the ultra
nightmare [ __ ] so I was like
okay and why can't they ever get the BFG
right in Annie doom movie in the rock
doom movie it's the rock has this gun
it's the BFG and he shoots it and it
just kind of it's like a plasma acid
thing that burns away a wall he's like
holy [ __ ] I'm like saying holy [ __ ]
doesn't make it a holy [ __ ] moment
granted I'm sure the rock didn't even
know what this is gonna look like they
were like yeah I just shoot it'll be big
just react like it's the biggest
explosion ever alright let's just have
it kind of make a plasma burn explosion
really anticlimactic BFG thing so this
movie has
BFG gnome-like alright here's a mulligan
for the BFG they got to get this right
there's a hallway a free enemy so I was
like alright just shoot it down the
hallway they're all gonna explode no
just to shoot them individually it's
like boom dead boom dead boom dead I was
like so it's a plasma rifle it's the
plasma rifle like just make a BFG kind
of like the nooks and Starship Troopers
something that when you shoot that
[ __ ] off you gotta take cover cuz it's
business I suggest anyone who makes a
doom movie should play a doom video game
though I'll give it this like the key
cards look like the key cards from the
new doom games and some of the sound
effects I was like that's from the new
doom games like yeah you got the IP so
here's some sound effects that we have
some they're gonna make it doom movie
make it good
okay guess not I kind of want to take it
easy on this movie because it just feels
like inexperience all-around
inexperience lack of budget both all of
the above at the end at the very end it
feels like it looks like dooms finally
about to happen
not really but finally but hey maybe a
sequel I doubt it this is walk away from
it going okay could have been doom but
it's a generic space zombie movie with a
group of Marines I didn't care about
that's not what Doom is in the end this
isn't a good movie it's not even fun
enough to be like oh but it was cheese
because I thought at first it was like
okay maybe this is gonna be one of those
cheesy fun action movies but it's just
boring dude annihilation is [ __ ]
alright so doom annihilation have you
seen it what did you think about it it's
on Netflix right now so you could watch
it for free if you'd like if you if you
want to if you want to do that to sell
or you can play Doom games probably a
better option but whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more throughout this entire review
my hair we're just kind of doing this as
I was like moving around it just kind of
like toast this that's cool how's your
day